for sure
uh the album comes out friday right well
[ __ ] tomorrow night i don't even know
what the [ __ ] what's today
today's wednesday yeah i don't even know
25th
25th so next week next week next friday
only for dolphins what is for dolphins
what is the um the latest with which
with you and uh
vice and and and the show because i i
remember that there was like a little
falling out and then i thought i saw you
back on or
is that done there's always a fallen now
when there's situations that are you
know when people are dishonest and
there's things that aren't without an
upheld but we overcame one of the
situations and we ended up putting out
season four
and that's the end of the contract did
four seasons five seasons
no couple on instagram on youtube and
now i'm i'm continuing that
100 myself on i'll be putting it up on
my youtube channel on action crossing
youtube
dad that's what i was gonna tell you
like you should just do that [ __ ] on
your own bro
i i mean it's my show i invented it i
named my [ __ ] they don't own it i own it
it's my hand
and i'm assuming we're still going to
have mayhem and bess and
and the crew uh well it's not really
feasible at this point and i
think everybody's going to be doing
their own shows right now everyone's
gearing up to do their own little thing
so i'm
i'm just sticking with what i'm just
like a vlog of my life
and my fitness and my journeys and my
food and
you know this is my life i'm saying i'm
a chef
i do these things i love food
i review food this is what i do this is
my [ __ ]
you know what i mean that's what i do so
i'm gonna continue always doing that and
everybody's gearing up for their own
style of show whatever they do it looks
[ __ ] everyone's stuff is looking
really fire
what what's uh what's the look at that
we create [ __ ] four spin-offs
well fourth [ __ ] idea that shit's
crazy
yeah i want to see i want to see i want
to spin off master all i do is
create [ __ ] ideas this let's do this
let's do this let's do this
and vice was really great at one point
for getting it done
yeah i think yeah we had some good
people in position
that would yes anything and i'm happy
about that because
it was a good idea for them and for us i
mean the idea that you had a tv show
watching ancient aliens while getting
high with your friends
is that not the best show ever created
that shit's incredible
that's gonna continue also my friend